all dating today really since uh 2000 is
about brand management if you are online
if you have an instagram account if you
are an influencer if you are on twitter
uh the what the number one dating app is
not tinder it's instagram right now and
are you cool enough to hang out so it's
all imagery it's all [ __ ] it's all
it's all uh brand management so you are
your own brand adam sosnick is the brand
of adam sauce yeah i was actually pretty
cool on instagram for a while and then i
got taken down now yeah zero percent
cool you got you got a 12 year old girl
in middle school who has an instagram
account she has her own brand she
doesn't realize it but she is her own
brand and so we we take that and we we
uh transition that over to the dating
scene right now the other thing is it's
kind of ridiculous to talk about dates
right now because nobody dates it's not
happy days anymore it's not the 50s it's
not like oh i'm going to take you out
and we're going to go have dinner at the
sock hop or whatever and get a
burger and a milkshake or some [ __ ] like
that it's not like that anymore the
number one way that men and women meet
each other is online and it is not it is
no longer plenty of fish it's no longer
uh match.com it's no longer eharmony it
is now this
he's cute he's not cute he's cute he's
not cute it's all about imagery and it's
all about like ordering humans online
exactly it is it is immediate um
we used to yeah but that's how they meet
initially but then they have to meet up
and then once yeah exactly once you get
to that point then then yes but it's uh
but that's the uh the precursor to all
of that so when we're talking about like
dates and this and that you know uh
depending on what the the league or the
classification of guy that you're gonna
get with you know there's leagues on on
tinder there's leagues on hinge there's
leagues on bumble and it's not
necessarily the people who are putting
themselves into that it's the actual app
itself that is doing that so when you go
on hinge or you go on especially hinge
because women get to you know choose the
guy rather than like make the mutual
connections on tinder but when you're on
tinder um you are in you are classified
it's almost like a like a tournament
ranking system so if you are getting
lots and lots of of hits as a as a
beautiful woman you're ranked
differently than women who are not and
the same goes for guys as well there are
far more guys of course on on apps than
there are women but um
but you're you're ranked and of course
if you want to get out of that rank you
can pay for it you can pay to get out of
that rank what do you think about people
who pay for apps
you can pay for like for extra boost
yeah in the algorithm yeah yeah yeah
well you can do that well what's how is
that in brand management brand
management how is that promotions
advertising marketing how is that any
have you ever
it's gonna be a bad question have you
ever used seeking arrangements no no
okay well like women of your caliber
from what you've described yourself as
right now they there are plenty of women
on seeking arrangements that do that
right now actually they reached out to
me they wanted a partnership we're not
doing it yes well they're looking and
people have have criticized you know
like fresh from freshman fed they've
criticized them for using like seeking
arrangements or it's like a sugaring
site or sugar daddies and that kind of
stuff and it's like well
guys use that who have uh get rich men
well high caliber high uh high value men
will use seeking arrangements because
the women that are on there are there
it's no [ __ ] and she's no [ __ ]
right now she's like this is what i
expect this is what i want to do this is
where i'm at whether or not you can get
that is is a different story but you
know what you want you've already like
put yourself to a point where you're
you've decided that you're in this
league and you're entitled to this kind
of treatment when you go on on a date so
why why not go on something like seeking
arrangements where you're going to find
guys who are they're going to say yeah
i'm going to take you to a nice
restaurant i'm going to we're going to
go have a really good i know sushi
dinner or whatever it is and and you're
going to be treated right
however when you get into that situation
you know what you're getting into you've
got a guy who expects also something in
return for that so it's it's i i expect
to i expect to be treated in a certain
way as well because if if we're both in
the same league and you have
entitlements then the guy has
entitlements as well now i'm not saying
he's entitled to sex i'm just saying
he's entitled to some respect he's just
entitled some integrity and certainty
certainly some honesty but it all comes
down to brand management how are you how
you are presenting yourself right now
and how you present yourself online
you're managing the brand of coco right
now just being on this show right now
you're managing your own brand hello
[Music]
you